(Ilana)
Yeah!
I'm making bank, bitch!
Oh, my God.
You are insane.
Ab, I'm becoming a mogul a la
Jay-Z, a la Martha Stewart,
a la Bethenny Frankel.
From "Housewives"?
Yeah.
Next thing you know, I'm
backstage at Barclays
with RiRi and Bebe--
Who?
Rihanna and Beyonce.
And we're just laughing
and sipping on champagne
with like, candlelight.
'Cause that happens
all the time.
RiRi leans in for a kiss
and then she--
Goes down on you.
Yeah.
Yeah, you-- you say
that story a lot.
Oh... cool.
Oh, my God!
I didn't know you had
plans with Lincoln.
We don't have plans.
We're just going to have sex at
one of these dogs' apartments.
Super classy.
I'd do it.
I'd pick up your poop,
you're worth it.
So I know why I missed
the window.
I jinxed myself.
Why, what do you mean?
'Cause I bought
too many condoms.
It's the story
of my life,
so just gonna
deal with it.
But I won't
make out with you.
That's what white people do,
that dog thing.
Black people don't
make out with dogs.
So what do you think is in
Jeremy's package?
Oh , look at you.
You're standoffish, huh?
I've narrowed it down
to a bunch of things.
I made a little list here.
Okay, so I think it's either,
um, clues to a mystery
that he's gonna solve,
a manly handcrafted axe,
or a really great belt.
Nah, dude,
it's a Fleshlight.
Ilana, why do you have to
ruin him for me?
It's not a Fleshlight.
(text alert)
It's healthy.
I gotta head back
to the office.
One of these dumb kids broke
his jaw on a Jawbreaker.
Why would you even do that?
It does exactly what
it says it's gonna do.
Lincoln, you gave all these dogs
all your love and now you're
leaving me like,
tight and dry.
I'll kick it
with you later.
Okay, cool.
See you later,
General Tso.
Is that his name?
Yeah, I name them based on
their personalities.
There's General Tso,
there's Dumbface.
That's Ballsack,
and that is star
of "Ugly Betty"
and "Who's the Boss?"
The wonderful,
the esteemed...
Judith Light!
(Abbi)
Oh, my God.
She is!
That's so Judith!
That is dead on!
All right,
I'll see y'all later.
All right, peace.
Later, Judith.
Judith, now that I know that
you are Judith Light,
I can't let you back
in that tiny-ass apartment.
We'll drop
these bitches off
and you're chilling
with me all day.
(whimpering)